I like my cafe I mean he said he's my
kind of guy
he kind of says it like it is
anybody can eat milk toast
no offense Gary Johnson I love you but
the fact of the matter is it's time for
strong leadership that's a lightning rod
for publicity McAfee is a mania I can
vouch for that personally and one day
hopefully I work very hard I could be
half the maniac that is John McAfee if
you listen to a lot of the outside
political media the libertarian national
convention here in Orlando is already a
done deal in terms of who's going to be
the presidential nominee Gary Johnson
but if you talk to actual delegates of
people who are in the building you get a
quite different point of view and part
of the reason for that is sitting right
across from me right now
presidential candidate John McAfee John
thank you very much for joining us for
reason TV Thank You Margaret I want to
ask you a question I'm asking everybody
includes as delegates in your view what
is the purpose of a Libertarian Party
presidential campaign and why do you
best fulfill what that purpose is and I
can tell you what the historical purpose
has been it's the Libertarian Party has
been like the 17 year locust only had
affairs every four years proffers a
libertarian candidate for president and
disappears for four days that's I'm not
I'm not making fun I'm just saying this
is how many people precede the actions
of the party well that's doing no one
any good meanwhile there are local
candidates I if you were at the debate
last night you heard me say I'm not
going to win be real and for those who
are supporting me I'm not dissing you
and don't lose hope because there's a
different way of winning oh it's not
going to happen please that we're all
deluding ourselves in private I hear
people's there's a chance of course not
of course not because we have a system
that's been in place for hundreds of
years
that has grown into a ossified machine
it's all about personalities do you
think it matters whether Hillary or
trunk gets elected if you do you haven't
watched the results after the previous
elections of every presidential election
for the past 60 years
in all cases the American people lose
something it's not us against Hillary or
Donald Trump or their Democrats or the
Republicans it is us against this
ridiculous twisted sick machine that
created them so part of this including
your phenomenal ad campaign so far is to
reorient the way people just think about
things yes we can win the solution to
any problem is way easier than anybody
ever dreams the the problem is is that
we buy into the the generally accepted
system of problem solving and in our
world
what is that system of problem solving
politics we have a problem let's elect
somebody to fix it we are trying to use
politics as the means of changing
politics please it can't work no if
we're clever we can use politics as a
sort of sleight of hand and say I'm
running for president and while I'm
doing that I'm using the eyeballs and
the attention and the manipulation of
our opponents which are not people but a
machine good god we can win we can win
but not in the way you think talk about
what that success looks like so we have
the failure both of this or a historical
futility let's say of the Libertarian
Party thing and also the failure of our
politics are at large what does success
look like in your brain for either of us
you know this is the unpleasant part
success in a political social economic
cultural environment is painful not not
hurtful not harmful but painful in all
cases where a social or political
upheaval has taken place they were not
all violent Mahatma Gandhi in India
throughout the the largest empire on the
planet without a good shot being fired
without being armed how did he do it he
came up with an idea really
passive resistance if you can get 10,000
people to stand in line to walk up to
collect salt and have the British beat
you into near subconsciousness while the
media is watching you will win are we
willing to do something that drastic
it's hard I am the most common objection
to your candidacy which I guess you've
probably heard once or twice so I'm sure
I have running is the unkind version
which I just read on Twitter is like we
already have a lunatic millionaire
running for president here that in a
totally weird electoral year where you
have this bogey called Donald Trump why
do we go after the international man of
mystery who's sort of shrouded in in
mythos and unpredictability I'm hoping
the difference between Trump and I is it
after he has the eyeballs you don't know
what to do other than if you'll beat up
that that protester I'll pay your legal
bill well yeah that's that's saying
something and maybe get some more
eyeballs I think I have the capacity to
stop being that lunatic for brief
periods like perhaps now and try to talk
rationally with people I heard you I
think if the Stossel debate elevate is
one of your prime motivations are on an
issue basis was that we are in a cyber
war with China right now and you have
you know interest and expertise in that
field is that indeed a main kind of
policy motivation for you know the cyber
security obviously I have to say
something about that because it is my
life in business and it's what I know
more of than anything else people allege
that I am fairly good at it and maybe my
perceptions are are sometimes correct
Forbes published his story where they
went out and talked to all of the
hackers and security people you know
about just learn to take McAfee claiming
run and they say well you know what we
think he's making America safer if you
don't win the nomination and if Austin
Peterson does you enthusiastically
endorsed him and you have emphatically
said that that is not the case with Gary
Johnson why well because the only
politician in the Libertarian Party is
running
president is Gary Johnson it is
impossible for me to sit here and say it
is that which must be replaced and then
support that thing which I say must be
replaced please okay who would I be
what would you believe with me what I
said next
what would failure look like from the LP
this year in terms of just a raw number
of votes presidential votes when one
percent has been the ceiling up till now
five percent is a threshold that means a
lot to the party what in your mind would
be failure in November for the
Libertarian Party what if we didn't
measure success in votes what if we
measured success in something else what
if we measured success in terms of
getting just two more states to call for
a constitutional convention well we need
to think about it well would that be
success hell yes
why the boats in the end do not matter
we get to say we got five percent of the
votes what did we change did we have a
better system are they is the government
less oppressive Dwight my freedom that
does the NSA stop spying on me if my tax
has gone down or disappeared no sir
so you cannot measure success in terms
of votes you have to measure success in
terms of change changing the
conversation and Libertarian Party has
been a definite accomplishment this
period by it's not active II thank you
very much for joining us look at the
recent TV I'm Matt Welsh